one of the other ways you can tell that
the 2024 election is really getting
going in Earnest is the frequency with
which attack ads are being released we
looked at Iran DeSantis ad we looked at
a trump ad we looked at a pack ad all
sorts of different ads lately a failed
former president Donald Trump has now
released such a ridiculously dangerous
ad uh that it's hard to believe anyone
would even fall for this but it's being
released for a reason and it's because
Trump knows his audience this ad that
Trump put out yesterday it's about 90
seconds 100 seconds long it invokes
multiple conspiracy theories it attacks
a trans woman
um it's really really insane stuff let's
take a look at it it's an invasion of
America
streets flooded with poison killing
Millions enemies and tyrants on opposite
sides of the globe laugh at us
[Music]
threat of nuclear Annihilation once
forgotten is now real again
America's weakness has become their
strength the global elitist okay so you
have to understand that the visual
components here are a big part of this
the great reset just appeared on the
screen that's that's uh the these what
deep state folks love to talk about the
great reset they love to demonize the
world economic Forum they had statistics
on screen about fentanyl seized at the
border now of course you might say to
yourself well if they're seizing the
fentanyl then it's not getting into the
country right like isn't that a good
sign that that our border patrol is
doing a good job by they don't care it's
all conjecture it's all propaganda it's
all performative send your kids to war
who tell you a woman is a man and a man
is a woman okay and at this point they
put trans woman Dylan Mulvaney at least
I think that's who this is up on the
screen they tell you a man is a woman
and a woman is a man this is completely
ridiculous when it comes to policy as
we've talked about before they are
dramatically overplaying their hand
nationally on this issue but within the
Maga right just being anti-trans for the
hell of it is playing really well these
are Big Applause lines when they do
events in public teach your children
their country their faith their beliefs
are a lie they have corrupted every
facet of American government webinar
against you
while they watch our Cities Burn and
violent crimes skyrocketed you and your
families pay the price remember long
term
crime is down violent crime is down the
murder rate is down long term there have
been shorter term uh spikes some of
which happened under Trump
and as we will talk about on the program
tomorrow
the red states of the United States are
dramatically more violent than the blue
States out of control inflation
economy wrecked now remember out of the
unemployment rate is extraordinarily low
job creation is high inflation has been
high it has now declined consecutively
for many many months under Joe Biden
every it's hard to go five seconds
without finding lies which is sort of
the way it is under with a trump speech
as well a nation in Decline this is Joe
Biden's America failing weak but one man
one movement can change all that for us
put America the middle class first
put the globalists the elitist and the
corrupt in their place bring back pride
and the American dream to let the world
know don't mess with us one man focused
on the true owners of this great land
one movement focused on the true
priorities make America great for us
again
okay
that's a trumpet
you might think is that a trailer to
some dystopian movie is that a satire is
that an SNL skit No that's actually a
trump ad including three times in the
hundred seconds the same video of when
Joe Biden tripped walking up to Air
Force One three times that's included
up and then riddled with corrosive and
destructive lies I guess if there's any
praise that we can give there's any
Silver Lining here it's the ad doesn't
include lies about who won in 2020 with
that is is that something that we could
find as a redeeming quality here
if you knew someone who said this stuff
to you in person right the the arguments
if you can even call them that that this
ad makes if you went to a dinner party
and someone rattled off what this ad
says to you you might say do you need a
psyche Val is this someone who has
become completely delusional and is
experiencing a paranoid delusional uh
event or state to the point that they
need to be evaluated because it is so
disconnected from reality
but this is all they have they've
abandoned policy notice that there's no
policy proposals there it's trans people
are bad and Biden's bad and World War
III you know but there's no actual
policy proposals there so this is all
they have this is my expectation maybe
not so much about what the primary will
be like because remember Trump hasn't
won the Primary yet he probably will he
hasn't won it yet but he's already
campaigning against Joe Biden in the
primary maybe they'll have to pretend to
talk about policy although maybe not but
we can already see that it's going to be
a general election once again where
whoever is the Republican nominee will
not utter a word about policy and it's
because they have lost on policy
if you're looking for the perfect
Mother's Day gift our sponsor Aura
frames creates incredible Ultra quality
digital frames we're displaying pictures
and videos you can pre-load the frame
with your favorite memories pictures
videos for Mom to see when she opens it
up you can update it with unlimited
photos and videos from anywhere using
the aura frames app no fees ever no
limits on storage Aura frames was voted
the number one digital picture frame by
wire cutter the strategist and Wired
Magazine my mom loves the frame I gave
her I also have an aura frame in my
house when we were just traveling I was
able to immediately add pictures which
pop up on my mom's frame and I've
noticed the photos look like real prints
such high resolution and the display is
calibrated so that you can not even tell
it's a screen Aura frames has an awesome
Mother's Day deal for my audience you'll
get up to thirty dollars off their
best-selling Carver map frame and free
shipping go to auraframes.com Pacman use
the code Pacman the link is in the
description